thuggish strike I've heard depressed
people who stopped antidepressant said
they never helped in the first place
what do you say to that mr. Peterson
hey that that's certainly possible
antidepressants don't necessarily work
for everyone my personal opinion is that
antidepressants work quite well for many
people whose lives are in decent order
so they have friends they have family
that love them they have a career
they're educated approximately to the
level of their intelligence they have
things to look forward to but for some
reason their mood is extremely distorted
and negative and I've seen
antidepressants have miraculous effects
on people like that I think they're less
likely to work when people have a
plethora of life problems which isn't
exactly the same thing as being
depressed you know like you think having
a terrible life is not the same thing as
being depressed although the two can
overlap and it isn't obvious to me that
people who you know maybe they have a
drinking problem or a drug abuse problem
and they're unemployed and they have a
pathological family and their friends
aren't good for them and you know they
they have a string of failures behind
them and they don't have much to look
forward to in the future at all about
its it's a lot for an antidepressant to
overcome but under those circumstances
maybe the antidepressants can help stave
off feelings like suicidal feelings and
that sort of thing but antidepressants
don't work for everyone but some people
they work really well for and if you're
depressed they're definitely worth the
try you know in a month if they're gonna
work also there are a variety of
different kinds of antidepressants and
you have to figure out dose and you have
to figure out when you should take them
during the day and you and you have to
figure out type so they're they're not a
cure they're a tool for helping control
negative emotion and they can be very
effective so but that doesn't mean that
there aren't people that they didn't
help so that's what I would say about
that